vado sempre con una gamba ma con tanta
voglia di vincere ok E mi sa che non che
la voglia non è bastata è difficilissima
sta parte raga come faccio a spiegare è
impossibile sono qua non posso schivarli
tutti sono 2.000 Lame cosa faccio ora il
salto sopra sto coso si può saltare
sopra
No vabbè sto male È piccolissimo non
posso centrarli tutti però attenzione
attenzione
incredibile no
forse questo tempo giusto stavolta Forse
sì no madonna guarda
Oh però attenzione che non c'ho ancora
il traguardo Eh quindi non facciamo
cagate
Ecco a posto A posto Let's go let's go
ancora ostacoli pure ci manca solo
questo Quanto lungo il percorso per
raggiungere quel punto no
senza una gamba ancora vivo perfetto
raga perfetto perfetto
Let's go my boys La professionalità
Grazie